i'm honored to serve as the first female  four-star officer  of the u.s public health service  commissioned corps  okay so you're not a female  you know no one wants to attack you for  that it's totally fine but when you get  up on stage and say something that  everyone knows is untrue and then demand  that we believe it you degrade the rest  of us  it's outrageous actually and not  everyone wants to play along  so this person is now an admiral to  memorialize the moment the babylon b  named rachel levin their man of the year  it's a joke but it's kind of true  in response to this twitter on which no  jokes are allowed suspended babylon b4  hates speech so per twitter policy when  a man calls himself a woman you have to  pretend that